When was the last time that you had an entire day completely free from digital distractions? No text messages, no email notifications, no social media, and no aimless internet browsing. It might be hard to think of the last time you even had a tech-free hour. These days, most of us live our lives tethered to our computers and our smartphones, which are unending sources of distraction. Sometimes it can feel impossible to concentrate deeply on anything for any time. anything for any significant length of time. And indeed, researchers have found evidence
你上一次整整一天完全没有受到数字干扰是什么时候？没有短信，没有电子邮件通知，没有社交媒体，也没有漫无目的的互联网浏览。可能很难想起你上一次哪怕有一个小时不接触科技产品是什么时候。如今，我们大多数人的生活都离不开电脑和智能手机，它们是无休止的干扰源。有时，想要在任何一段时间内专注于任何事情似乎都是不可能的。事实上，研究人员已经发现了证据，
that over the past couple of decades, people's attention spans have shrunk considerably. So how has the rise of the internet and digital devices affected our ability to focus and pay attention? What does it mean to pay attention to something anyway? When you're being bombarded by different tasks, notifications, and emails, is it possible to multitask and deal with them all effectively?
在过去的几十年里，人们的注意力持续时间已经大大缩短。那么，互联网和数字设备的兴起是如何影响我们专注和集中注意力的能力的呢？到底什么是“关注”某事？当你被各种任务、通知和电子邮件轰炸时，是否有可能同时处理它们并保持高效？
Or is productive multitasking a myth? How can understanding the science of attention help us to regain our focus when we need it, to improve both our productivity and our happiness? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Gloria Mark, a psychologist and the Chancellor's Professor of Informatics at the University of California, Irvine.
还是说高效的多任务处理只是一个神话？了解注意力的科学如何帮助我们在需要时重新集中注意力，从而提高我们的工作效率和幸福感？欢迎收听美国心理学会的旗舰播客《心理学谈话》，该节目旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我今天的嘉宾是心理学家、加州大学欧文分校信息学教授格洛丽亚·马克博士。
Dr. Mark studies how people interact with technology in their everyday lives and how technology affects our attention, multitasking, mood, and stress level. She studies people's behavior in real-world settings, and she's found that our attention spans have been shrinking over the past two decades. Her new book published in January is called Attention Span, a groundbreaking way to restore balance, happiness, and productivity. Dr. Mark, thank you for joining me today. Thank you so much for having me. Most of us probably think that we know what it means when we say we pay attention to something. But you wrote in your book that there are different kinds of attention.
马克博士研究人们在日常生活中如何与技术互动，以及技术如何影响我们的注意力、多任务处理、情绪和压力水平。她研究人们在现实环境中的行为，并发现过去二十年来我们的注意力持续时间一直在缩短。她一月份出版的新书名为《注意力跨度：恢复平衡、幸福和生产力的开创性方法》。马克博士，感谢您今天参加我们的节目。非常感谢您的邀请。我们大多数人可能认为我们知道“关注”某事意味着什么。但您在书中写道，注意力有不同的种类。
Can you talk about that? What are the different kinds of attentions that we experience in our everyday life? Let me actually start out by talking about what William James, the father of psychology, says about attention. So back in the 19th century, he said, everyone knows what attention is. It's the taking possession by the mind in clear and vivid form of one out of what seems several simultaneously possible objects or trains of thought. Of course everyone knows what attention is. We all believe we know what attention is, but it's a lot more complicated than that.
您能谈谈这个吗？我们在日常生活中体验到的注意力有哪些不同种类？其实，我想先谈谈心理学之父威廉·詹姆斯关于注意力的论述。早在19世纪，他就说过，每个人都知道什么是注意力。它是心灵以清晰生动的形式，从似乎同时存在的多个可能对象或思维链中，占有其中一个。当然，每个人都知道什么是注意力。我们都认为自己知道什么是注意力，但它比那要复杂得多。
So when I was studying attention, it occurred to me that you can be very engaged in something. and you can put in a lot of mental effort. You know, if I'm reading an article, you know, I really have to, it can be challenging for me. On the other hand, there's a lot of things we do that are not at all challenging, but we're very engaged in. So when we're playing solitaire or, you know, playing simple games online, or, you know, if a person is gardening, you know, they might be very engaged and not at all challenged. So we set out to study different kinds of attention when people use their devices. And what we did was we probed people throughout the day. And we asked them, you know, at this point in time, want you to respond very quickly and tell us how engaged were you in what you just did and how challenged were you in what you just did.
所以，当我研究注意力时，我意识到你可以非常投入地做某事，并且可以投入大量的脑力。你知道，如果我在读一篇文章，我真的必须这样做，这对我来说可能很有挑战性。另一方面，我们做的很多事情一点也不具挑战性，但我们却非常投入。所以，当我们玩纸牌游戏，或者在网上玩简单的游戏，或者如果一个人在园艺时，他们可能会非常投入，但一点也不觉得有挑战性。因此，我们着手研究人们使用设备时注意力的不同种类。我们所做的是在一天中不断地询问人们。我们问他们，在这个时间点，请快速回答并告诉我们，你对刚才做的事情有多投入，以及你觉得刚才做的事情有多大的挑战性。
We find that when people are engaged and challenged, there seems to be rhythms in the day when this happens. And people seem to have peaks of times when they do this. we call this focused attention. Tends to be late morning, and again, mid to late afternoon, about two to three. And when people are very engaged in something and not at all challenged, we call that road activity. Lots of things that people do are road activity when they're online. It could be simple games. It could be even reading the news or doing social media.
我们发现，当人们既投入又有挑战感时，一天中似乎会出现这种节奏。人们似乎在某些时段会达到这种状态的峰值。我们称之为“专注的注意力”。这往往发生在上午晚些时候，以及下午中后期，大约两点到三点。当人们对某事非常投入但完全没有挑战感时，我们称之为“机械活动”。人们上网时做的很多事情都是机械活动。可能是简单的游戏。也可能是阅读新闻或使用社交媒体。
They tend to do that relatively. uniformly throughout the day. But we do find that focused attention occurs in rhythms, and it seems to correspond to the ebb and flow of our mental resources that we have available. Well, I mentioned in the introduction that you have found evidence that our attention spans have shrunk in recent years, at least as measured by how long people spend on tasks and screens at work. Can you talk about that, how much have our attention spans shrunk? So, you know, we started measuring this back in 2004. And at the time, the measures that we used were stopwatches, because that was the most precise thing we had at the time. We would shadow people with stopwatches. For every single activity they
他们往往在一天中相对均匀地做这些事情。但我们确实发现，专注的注意力是有节奏的，它似乎与我们可用的心理资源的起伏相对应。嗯，我在介绍中提到，您已经发现证据表明我们的注意力持续时间近年来有所缩短，至少从人们在工作中处理任务和屏幕的时间来看是这样。您能谈谈这个吗，我们的注意力持续时间缩短了多少？所以，我们从2004年开始测量这个。当时，我们使用的测量工具是秒表，因为那是我们当时拥有的最精确的东西。我们会用秒表跟踪人们。对于他们做的每一项活动，
did, we would record the start time and the stop time. So you're on a screen where you're working at a Word doc, as soon as you get to that screen, we clicked start time. As soon as they turned away and checked email, we clicked stop time for the word document, start time for the email. But fortunately, sophisticated computer logging methods were developed. And so, of course, we switched to those. So back in 2004, we found the average attention span on any screen to be two and a half minutes on average. throughout the years, it became shorter. So around 2012, we found it to be 75 seconds. This is with logging techniques. This is an average. And then in the last five, six years, we found it to average about 47 seconds. And others have replicated this result within a few seconds. So it seems to be quite robust. Now, another way to think about this result is the median. The median means the midpoint of observations. The median is 40 seconds. And what this means is that half of all the measurements that we found were 40 seconds or less of people's attention spans. Now, you know,
我们都会记录开始时间和结束时间。所以，当你坐在屏幕前处理Word文档时，一旦你进入那个屏幕，我们就点击开始时间。一旦他们转过身去查看电子邮件，我们就点击Word文档的结束时间，并开始记录电子邮件的开始时间。但幸运的是，复杂的计算机日志记录方法被开发出来了。所以，我们当然转向了这些方法。回到2004年，我们发现任何屏幕上的平均注意力持续时间平均为两分半钟。多年来，它变得越来越短。所以大约在2012年，我们发现它是75秒。这是使用日志记录技术得出的。这是一个平均值。然后在过去五六年里，我们发现它平均约为47秒。其他人也在几秒钟内复制了这个结果。所以它似乎非常稳健。现在，考虑这个结果的另一种方法是中位数。中位数意味着观察值的中间点。中位数是40秒。这意味着我们发现的所有测量值中，有一半是40秒或更短的注意力持续时间。现在，你知道，
obviously because we're talking about averages and medians, sometimes people do spend longer, but quite a good bit of the time, their attention spans are much shorter and within average coming to 47 seconds. So why is this a problem? I mean, you know, since it seems to be happening almost universally at this point, is this just the new normal? It seems to be the new normal because we seem to have reached a steady state over the last five or six years where these are the measures that we're seeing. Is this a good thing? I would argue it's not a good thing for the following reasons. First of all, we find in our research a correlation between frequency of attention switching and stress. So the faster the attention switching occurs, stress as measured by,
显然，因为我们谈论的是平均值和中位数，有时人们确实会花费更长的时间，但相当长的时间里，他们的注意力持续时间要短得多，平均为47秒。那么，为什么这是一个问题呢？我的意思是，既然这一点似乎在目前几乎普遍发生，这只是“新常态”吗？这似乎是新常态，因为在过去五六年里，我们似乎已经达到了一个稳定状态，即我们看到的这些测量结果。这是一件好事吗？我认为这不是一件好事，原因如下。首先，我们在研究中发现注意力切换频率与压力之间存在相关性。所以注意力切换发生得越快，压力就越大，通过佩戴心率监测器来测量，
people wearing heart rate monitors. We show that stress goes up. We know from decades of research in the laboratory that when people multitask, they experience stress. Blood pressure rises. There's a physiological marker in the body that indicates people are stressed. And, you know, in our studies, we've also simply asked people with well-valent instruments to report their stress, their perceived stress.
我们显示压力会上升。我们从实验室几十年的研究中得知，当人们进行多任务处理时，他们会感到压力。血压升高。身体中有一个生理指标表明人们处于压力之下。而且，在我们的研究中，我们也只是用有效的工具要求人们报告他们的压力，他们感知的压力。
And it's reported to be higher the faster that we measure attention shifting. So all of these measures seem to be consistent. I will also measure that when people shift their attention so fast, and this is multitasking when you keep switching your attention among different activities, people make more errors, and that's been shown in studies in the real world with physicians, nurses, pilots. We also know that performance slows. Why?
而且我们测量到的注意力转换越快，报告的压力就越大。所以所有这些测量结果似乎是一致的。我还要提到，当人们切换注意力如此之快时——这就是当你不断在不同活动之间切换注意力时的多任务处理——人们会犯更多的错误，这在现实世界中对医生、护士、飞行员的研究中已经得到证实。我们也知道表现会变慢。为什么？
Because there's something called a switch cost. So every time you switch your attention, you have to reorient to that new activity, that new thing you're paying attention to, and it takes a little bit of time. So imagine if you're writing, let's say you're writing a chapter and you suddenly stop what you're doing and you switch and do something else and then you come back to it. It's going to take you some time to reconstruct. You know, what was I writing? What was the topic I was thinking about? What were the words I was using? That takes a bit of time. And so we incur these switch costs throughout the day as we're switching our attention. And, you know, this creates more effort. It uses more of our
因为有一种东西叫做“切换成本”。所以每次你切换注意力时，你都必须重新定向到那个新的活动，那个你正在关注的新事物，这需要一点时间。所以想象一下，如果你在写作，假设你在写一章，你突然停止了你正在做的事情，切换去做别的事情，然后你又回到它。你需要一些时间来重构。你知道，我在写什么？我在思考什么主题？我在用什么词？这需要一点时间。因此，当我们切换注意力时，我们在一天中会产生这些切换成本。而且，这创造了更多的努力。它消耗了我们更多的
very precious mental resources on top of the work that we actually need to do. You've also found that some switching is good. It's normal during the course of a day so that you might really concentrate on something for a length of time. And then you take a break and maybe you go online or maybe if you're working from home, you put in a load of laundry. or you take a walk. I mean, isn't that something that we actually need to do? Absolutely. It's so important that we take breaks because if you work until you get exhausted, then, of course, you can get burn up. It's so important to take breaks and replenish. And by taking breaks, we have more energy, we have more attentional capacity,
非常宝贵的心理资源，除了我们实际需要做的工作之外。您还发现一些切换是有益的。在一天中这是正常的，这样你可能会真正专注于某事一段时间。然后你休息一下，也许你上网，或者如果你在家工作，你洗了一堆衣服，或者去散步。我的意思是，这难道不是我们实际上需要做的事情吗？绝对是。休息非常重要，因为如果你工作到精疲力竭，那么，当然，你可能会崩溃。休息和补充能量非常重要。通过休息，我们有更多的精力，我们有更多的注意力容量，
and we can actually do more. We can be more productive. The problem is that in our current world, many work environments, people neglect to take meaningful breaks. And, you know, we get ourselves into a position where we end up having our performance suffers as a result. Now, if you're going to take a break, it's really important to take a break at a point in the task that's called a break point. And a break point is a natural stopping point in a task. So going back to the writing example, if I'm writing something, a break point would be at the end of a section or even at the end of a paragraph, right? But at a point where when I come back to it, then there's not going to be
我们实际上可以做得更多。我们可以更有效率。问题在于，在当今世界，许多工作环境中，人们忽略了进行有意义的休息。而且，我们让自己陷入了一种导致表现受损的境地。现在，如果你要休息，在任务中被称为“断点”的点休息非常重要。断点是任务中的一个自然停止点。所以回到写作的例子，如果我在写东西，断点会在一个章节的末尾，甚至在一个段落的末尾，对吧？但在一个点上，当我回来时，就不会有
a lot of effort for me to have to reconstruct what I was doing. I've already finished that part. If you interrupt yourself in the middle of doing something as opposed to a natural stopping point, you use up a lot more mental resources and it's also more stressful. Well, for people who want to schedule breaks, who really want to intentionally make the changes that you're talking about, what do you think about programs? such as internet blockers that prevent people from going online during certain hours of the day so that you can force yourself to be more focused. Do you think that those are effective? We've done a study with internet blockers, and it turns out it very much depends on an individual's
很多努力让我不得不重构我正在做的事情。我已经完成了那部分。如果你在做某事的过程中打断自己，而不是在自然停止点，你会消耗更多的心理资源，而且压力也更大。那么，对于那些想要安排休息时间，真正想要有意做出您所谈论的改变的人，您如何看待程序？例如，在一天中的某些小时内阻止人们上网的互联网拦截器，这样你就可以强迫自己更专注。您认为这些有效吗？我们做过一项关于互联网拦截器的研究，结果发现这在很大程度上取决于个人的
personality. So people who have poor self-regulation skills can benefit from these kinds of blockers. You know, essentially what you're doing is you're offloading the work of self-regulation onto the software. And the software becomes a proxy agent for you, right? It's doing the work. It turns out people who have good self-regulation skills, so people who score low in impulsivity as a trade, people who score high in conscientiousness. These These are people who are actually harmed by these blockers. Why? Because these are people who are very good at taking breaks and coming right back to work.
个性。所以自我调节能力差的人可以从这些拦截器中受益。你知道，本质上你所做的是将自我调节的工作卸载到软件上。软件成为了你的代理人，对吧？它在做这项工作。事实证明，自我调节能力好的人，即在冲动性特质上得分低的人，在尽责性上得分高的人。这些人实际上是被这些拦截器伤害了。为什么？因为这些人非常擅长休息并立即回到工作中。
They can take a break. They can go to social media. They can go to a new site. And they can take a break, relax themselves. Then they can come back to work. In this study, we took away their opportunity to take a quick on- break and they got burned out. They worked straight through. They didn't take breaks. On the whole, I prefer that people develop their own agency, their own self-efficacy in controlling their
他们可以休息。他们可以去社交媒体。他们可以去新闻网站。他们可以休息，放松自己。然后他们可以回到工作中。在这项研究中，我们剥夺了他们进行快速在线休息的机会，他们精疲力竭了。他们一直工作到底。他们没有休息。总的来说，我更希望人们发展自己的代理权，即他们在控制自己的
attention. These software blockers can be good at times, but I think it's far more important and that people learn to develop their own skills to control their attention. You know, a lot has been written about the Pomodoro technique, which is basically, you said a timer for every 25 minutes to do, and then you agree, you're going to work straight through for 25 minutes, the timer goes off and you get a five-minute break. What about that as sort of a low-tech blocker? Well, that's fine, but there are individual differences. and, you know, some people would be able to work longer than what the Pomodora technique dictates.
注意力方面的自我效能感。这些软件拦截器有时可能很好，但我认为更重要的是人们学习发展自己的技能来控制自己的注意力。你知道，关于番茄工作法已经写了很多，基本上，你设置一个25分钟的计时器来做某事，然后你同意，你将连续工作25分钟，计时器响起，你得到五分钟的休息。作为一种低科技拦截器，您觉得怎么样？嗯，那很好，但存在个体差异。而且，有些人能够工作的时间比番茄工作法规定的要长。
Some people would work less. I think it's much more important that people become self-aware of their own level of energy and the amount of attentional resources they have available and take breaks according to what their own levels are. So, you know, I've learned to do this. I've learned to become more aware of what my own capacity is. And when I start feeling tired, that's the point when I take a break. If I know I've got a really hard task to do, I might schedule a break before I start doing that task so I can replenish myself and then right after so that I can, you know, build back up
有些人工作的时间会更短。我认为更重要的是，人们要对自己的能量水平和他们拥有的注意力资源量有自我意识，并根据自己的水平进行休息。所以，我知道我已经学会了这样做。我已经学会了更加意识到我自己的能力是什么。当我开始感到疲倦时，那就是我休息的时候。如果我知道我有一项非常艰巨的任务要做，我可能会在开始做那项任务之前安排一次休息，这样我就可以补充自己，然后在任务之后立即安排一次，这样我就可以，你知道，重建
the resources that I expended. The worst thing you can do, the worst thing is to schedule back-to-back Zoom meetings without breaks, that it just gets us exhausted. There's no transition between these meetings. So we need to schedule in transitions between these kinds of hard tasks. When we're talking about attention and attention spans, there's something a little bit different but related, which is the concept of flow. Can you explain what that is?
我消耗的资源。你能做的最糟糕的事情，最糟糕的事情就是安排背靠背的Zoom会议而不休息，这只会让我们精疲力竭。这些会议之间没有过渡。所以我们需要在这些艰巨的任务之间安排过渡。当我们谈论注意力和注意力持续时间时，有一个稍微不同但相关的东西，即“心流”的概念。您能解释一下那是什么吗？
because that is a kind of attention. And it's very, very different from what we've just been talking about. That's right. So flow is a type of attention that the psychologist Mihaliyi, Schiiksa Mihaliki, discovered. And it's what he calls the optimal state of attention. It's when people are so immersed in something that time just doesn't seem to matter. And so it's when we. It's when we are at our peak creativity.
因为那是一种注意力。它与我们刚才谈论的内容非常、非常不同。没错。所以心流是心理学家米哈里·契克森米哈赖发现的一种注意力类型。这就是他所说的“最佳注意力状态”。当人们如此沉浸在某事中，以至于时间似乎根本不重要。所以这就是当我们。这就是当我们处于创造力巅峰时。
We're using the optimal amount of challenge of our skills. So if we're not challenged enough in whatever your skill happens to be, you won't go into flow. If you're challenged too much in your skill, you won't go into flow. It'll be too hard. So there's that sweet spot that you have to hit to go into flow. flow. So before I went into psychology, I actually had studied fine arts and used to be an artist, and I would get into flow regularly. And it's the nature of the work of, you know, being an artist and, you know, being creative, that I could regularly get into flow. Now, as a scientist, I rarely get into
我们正在使用对我们技能的最佳挑战量。所以，如果我们在任何技能上没有受到足够的挑战，你就不会进入心流。如果你的技能受到太大的挑战，你就不会进入心流。那会太难了。所以有一个你必须达到的“甜蜜点”才能进入心流。所以在我进入心理学之前，我实际上学习过美术，曾经是一名艺术家，我会定期进入心流。这是作为一名艺术家和具有创造力的工作的本质，我可以定期进入心流。现在，作为一名科学家，我很少进入
flow because of the nature of my work where I have to be very analytical. And I have, you know, I have to use very careful thought. Is that a bad thing? No, not at all. It's, it's very rewarding. It's just I realize that the nature of my work and the nature of a lot of knowledge work is such that it may not be conducive to flow. But sometimes I get into flow if I'm in, say, a brainstorming session with other people. We might get into a kind of group flow where, you know, we're just everyone is feeding off of each other's ideas. But, you know, in my typical day-to-day life now, I generally don't get into flow. And it's not a bad thing. Let's talk for a minute about the effect of the internet and devices on children's attention span. Most of your research has been
心流，因为我的工作性质，我必须非常分析。而且我必须，你知道，我必须使用非常仔细的思考。这是一件坏事吗？不，一点也不。它非常有回报。只是我意识到我的工作性质和许多知识工作的性质使得它可能不利于心流。但有时如果我处于，比如说，与其他人的头脑风暴会议中，我会进入心流。我们可能会进入一种群体心流，你知道，每个人都在从彼此的想法中汲取灵感。但是，你知道，在我现在典型的日常生活中，我通常不会进入心流。这不是一件坏事。让我们花一分钟谈谈互联网和设备对儿童注意力持续时间的影响。您的大部分研究都是
with adults, but kids are spending a lot of time on devices as well. Are they going to have even more trouble with attention than those of us who first experience this level of distraction as adults? This is something that I think we should be very concerned about as a society. So it turns out children that are as young as two to four years old, they already average two and a half hours of screen time a day. And when they get to be between five and eight, they average about three hours of screen time a day. Now, most of that screen time, it's TV and YouTube viewing. But children also do a lot of gaming, right? So we know from a lot of laboratory studies that when children are very young, they're a lot more susceptible to distraction than older children.
针对成年人的，但孩子们也在设备上花费了大量时间。他们会比我们这些成年后才第一次体验这种程度干扰的人有更多的注意力问题吗？这是我认为我们作为一个社会应该非常关注的事情。事实证明，两到四岁的儿童，他们每天平均已经有两半小时的屏幕时间。当他们达到五到八岁时，他们每天平均有大约三个小时的屏幕时间。现在，大部分屏幕时间是电视和YouTube观看。但孩子们也做很多游戏，对吧？所以我们从许多实验室研究中得知，当孩子们非常年幼时，他们比大一点的孩子更容易受到干扰。
And when they're distracted, it takes them longer to get back and focus again on that thing that they weren't distracted from. So, you know, I worry that when young children are spending so much time on the screen, it acculturates them to think that this is normal behavior to be on a screen. The problem is that when children are very young, there are certain parts of their brain that are not yet mature. So their ability to self-control
当他们分心时，他们需要更长的时间才能回来并再次专注于他们没有分心的事情。所以，你知道，我担心当幼儿在屏幕上花费这么多时间时，它会使他们适应认为在屏幕上是正常的行为。问题在于，当孩子们非常年幼时，他们大脑的某些部分尚未成熟。所以他们自我控制的能力
and a part of the brain called executive function. And executive function is, you can think of it as the governor of the mind. So it manages things like decision-making and setting priorities of, of what we should be paying attention to. It helps manage interference of peripheral stimuli in the environment. And executive function is not yet well developed,
以及大脑中一个叫做“执行功能”的部分。执行功能，你可以把它看作是心灵的管理者。所以它管理诸如决策和设定我们应该关注什么的优先级之类的事情。它有助于管理环境中外围刺激的干扰。而执行功能尚未发育良好，
and children are sitting in front of screens, and they're exposed to all kinds of potential distractions. So I think this is not a good idea. Children need self-control for learning. And more and more, we're seeing schools having a lot of online learning available for kids. And kids need self-control as a skill to be able to search for information, to do math problems online, to read and write without being distracted. I find it problematic that we're putting children into a digital world. before some very critical mental functions are fully developed.
孩子们坐在屏幕前，他们接触到各种潜在的干扰。所以我认为这不是一个好主意。孩子们需要自我控制来进行学习。而且我们越来越多地看到学校为孩子们提供大量的在线学习。孩子们需要自我控制作为一种技能，以便能够搜索信息、在线做数学题、阅读和写作而不分心。我发现我们把孩子们置于一个数字世界中是有问题的，在一些非常关键的心理功能完全发育之前。
I don't think kids are really ready for that. Can focus be taught? I mean, you seem to be implying that we need to be doing something, particularly with children, so that they aren't constantly distracted. But, I mean, how do you teach somebody to focus on something? Well, for children, I think the best thing children can do is to do, activity off screen. And I think they would learn to focus, whether it's, you know, playing outside, reading books is an excellent way to get children to focus. If we're talking about adults,
我不认为孩子们真的准备好了。专注力可以被教导吗？我的意思是，您似乎在暗示我们需要做些什么，特别是针对儿童，这样他们就不会不断分心。但是，我的意思是，你如何教某人专注于某事？嗯，对于孩子们，我认为孩子们能做的最好的事情就是做屏幕外的活动。我认为他们会学会专注，无论是，你知道，在外面玩，读书是让孩子们专注的一种极好的方式。如果我们谈论的是成年人，
I think that one of the best things that adults can do is to make sure that your internal tank of mental resources is kept at high capacity. So when you have a full, full tank of resources, you can focus much better than when you're just spent. You know, when your resources have just drained because you're doing hard work all day, you're switching your attention a lot. It's going to be very, very hard to focus. And there are things we can do to build up those resources. So we can, one of the best things you can do is to get a really good night's sleep. I know everyone says, of course, we know you should get a good night's sleep, but let me tell you what happens when you don't. When people accumulate what's called sleep debt,
我认为成年人能做的最好的事情之一就是确保你的内部心理资源罐保持在高容量。所以当你有一个装满资源的罐子时，你可以比当你精疲力竭时专注得多。你知道，当你的资源因为你整天做艰苦的工作而耗尽时，你切换注意力很多。要专注将是非常、非常困难的。而且我们可以做一些事情来建立这些资源。所以我们可以，你能做的最好的事情之一就是睡个好觉。我知道每个人都说，当然，我们知道你应该睡个好觉，但让我告诉你当你没有这样做时会发生什么。当人们积累了所谓的“睡眠债”，
and sleep debt is the accumulation of loss of sleep. If you need eight hours of sleep a night, and I need eight hours of sleep at night, but if you're only getting six hours a night, that difference is called a sleep debt. And if you're consistently getting six hours of sleep a night, you're accumulating sleep debt. And we know that the greater the sleep debt, the shorter the attention spans. And what do people do when they have a lot of sleep debt? We found that they tend to do more lightweight activities like social media. They just don't have the resources to be able to focus and do hard work. So they do what's easy based on the amount of resources that they have available.
睡眠债是睡眠损失的积累。如果你每晚需要八小时睡眠，我也需要八小时睡眠，但如果你每晚只睡六小时，那个差异就叫做睡眠债。如果你每晚持续只睡六小时，你就在积累睡眠债。而且我们知道，睡眠债越大，注意力持续时间就越短。当人们有大量睡眠债时，他们会做什么？我们发现他们倾向于做更多轻量级的活动，比如社交媒体。他们只是没有资源来专注和做艰苦的工作。所以他们根据他们拥有的资源量做容易的事情。
Let's switch topics for a minute to something else that you talk about in your book, which is how TV and movies have changed in the past few decades. You're right that the pace of television and movies has sped up and things like the length of each camera shot. They're getting shorter. Why is that? And are those changes affecting our attention? Or is this happening because the people who are creating these things already know that we have no attention anymore?
让我们切换话题一分钟，谈谈您在书中谈到的另一件事，即电视和电影在过去几十年里是如何变化的。您写道，电视和电影的节奏加快了，诸如每个镜头长度之类的事情。它们变得越来越短。为什么会这样？这些变化是否在影响我们的注意力？还是说这发生是因为创造这些东西的人已经知道我们不再有注意力了？
So I was very surprised to learn that TV and film shot lengths have decreased over the years. They started out much longer. They now average about four seconds a shot length. That's on average. If you watch MTV music videos, they're much shorter. They're only a couple of seconds. So we've become accustomed to seeing very fast shot lengths when we look at TV and film. Even commercials have shortened in length.
所以我很惊讶地了解到电视和电影的镜头长度多年来一直在减少。它们开始时要长得多。它们现在平均大约四秒一个镜头长度。这是平均水平。如果你看MTV音乐视频，它们要短得多。它们只有几秒钟。所以当我们看电视和电影时，我们已经习惯了看到非常快的镜头长度。甚至广告的长度也缩短了。
Commercials used to be much longer. Now it's not uncommon to see six-second commercials even shorter than that. Now, it's a chicken and egg question. We don't know if TV and film have affected our attention spans on computers and phones. We don't know if our attention spans have affected the decision-making of film editors and directors. We don't know exactly if there is any causal connection. We see these two parallel trends. It could be the case that directors and editors are influenced by their own short attention spans when they create these film shots. Or it could be.
广告过去要长得多。现在看到六秒的广告甚至更短的广告并不罕见。现在，这是一个先有鸡还是先有蛋的问题。我们不知道电视和电影是否影响了我们在电脑和手机上的注意力持续时间。我们不知道我们的注意力持续时间是否影响了电影剪辑师和导演的决策。我们不知道是否存在任何因果联系。我们看到这两个平行的趋势。可能是导演和剪辑师在创作这些电影镜头时受到他们自己短注意力持续时间的影响。或者可能是。
that they're creating short film shots because they think that's what the viewer wants to see. But this has become quite ubiquitous. In fact, on YouTube, there's a particular YouTube aesthetic which uses jump cuts. So when you're watching a YouTube film, the film becomes very jumpy, right? It's the natural pauses that people make when they speak is removed. So the idea is to pack more content into a shorter amount of time. So, you know, we're seeing short lengths of content from all directions. It's not just what we're attending to on computers and phones. But I think you found that some of this we're doing to ourselves. Like I know some people who feel like there's so time crunched that when they want to listen to a podcast, they turn up the
他们正在创作短电影镜头，因为他们认为那是观众想看到的。但这已经变得相当普遍。事实上，在YouTube上，有一种特定的YouTube美学，它使用跳剪。所以当你观看YouTube电影时，电影变得非常跳跃，对吧？人们说话时的自然停顿被删除了。所以这个想法是在更短的时间内塞入更多的内容。所以，你知道，我们从各个方向看到短长度的内容。不仅仅是我们关注电脑和手机上的内容。但我认为您发现其中一些是我们自己造成的。比如我知道有些人觉得时间太紧了，以至于当他们想听播客时，他们把
speed to 1.5 or 2, you know, and then listen to it. I mean, Why are we doing this to ourselves? And is this helping? You know, I myself have sometimes done that. Why do we do this? You know, there's a number of reasons. I can't say exactly why we do. It could be because we want to fit more content into a shorter amount of time
速度调到1.5或2，你知道，然后听它。我的意思是，为什么我们要对自己这样做？这有帮助吗？你知道，我自己有时也这样做。为什么我们这样做？你知道，有很多原因。我不能确切地说为什么我们这样做。可能是因为我们想在更短的时间内塞入更多的内容，
because there's so much content available, right? We're talking about access to the world's largest candy store, and we want to sample all the way. that are available. So, of course, you might want to speed up the podcast so that you can simply take more in and quickly get to your next favorite podcast. So I don't know exactly why we're doing it on ourselves. It could be also out of habit.
因为有太多的内容可用，对吧？我们谈论的是进入世界上最大的糖果店，我们想尝试所有可用的方式。所以，当然，你可能想加快播客的速度，这样你就可以简单地吸收更多内容并快速进入你下一个最喜欢的播客。所以我不知道为什么我们对自己这样做。这也可能是出于习惯。
We're just used to listening to things faster. But we do have, you know, all of this content available to us at our fingertips. within milliseconds. And so, you know, perhaps we just want to sample as much as we possibly can. Now, during the pandemic, many people have switched to remote work, which I'm guessing has meant more emails, more messages on Slack and teams, and workers have to deal with all of this. How do you think this is affecting people's attention and focus? Do you even know, is it too soon to say? Yeah, so I've worked on a survey with colleagues. So we have people self-reports. They've reported that it's hard to focus. I've done other work where we're looking at team, team interaction in remote work and have picked up some information from that. People do report having a hard time focusing. It's a different kind of distraction than you would have a in a workplace. Of course, you're distracted by the pile of dirty laundry that you're looking at.
我们只是习惯了听得更快。但我们确实有，你知道，所有这些内容触手可及。在几毫秒内。所以，你知道，也许我们只是想尽可能多地尝试。现在，在疫情期间，许多人转向了远程工作，我猜这意味着更多的电子邮件，更多的Slack和Teams上的消息，员工必须处理所有这些。您认为这如何影响人们的注意力和专注力？您甚至知道吗，现在说还为时过早吗？是的，所以我与同事合作进行了一项调查。所以我们有人们的自我报告。他们报告说很难专注。我做了其他工作，我们正在研究远程工作中的团队互动，并从中收集了一些信息。人们确实报告说很难专注。这与你在工作场所会有的干扰不同。当然，你会被你看到的脏衣服堆分心。
In a workplace, you might be distracted by ambient noise in the workplace. We do know that it makes a difference whether people have a private workspace at home where it can be quiet or whether they have to share a public working space with others, which is more distracting. Some people might go to a cafe to work. And of course, that creates another type of distraction. So a lot of it very much depends on the environment where the person is working. We also know that, you know, if you're remote from your colleagues, you can't really signal to them when is a good time to interrupt. If you're in a workplace, and especially if you can see your colleagues, you can see when they just hung up the phone, then you know it might be a nice time to walk over and talk to them,
在工作场所，你可能会被工作场所的环境噪音分心。我们确实知道，人们在家中是否有私人工作空间可以安静，或者他们是否必须与他人共享公共工作空间，这会有所不同，后者更令人分心。有些人可能会去咖啡馆工作。当然，这会产生另一种干扰。所以很大程度上取决于人工作的环境。我们也知道，你知道，如果你远离你的同事，你真的无法向他们发出什么时候是打断的好时机的信号。如果你在工作场所，特别是如果你能看到你的同事，你可以看到他们什么时候刚挂断电话，那么你就知道这可能是一个走过去和他们交谈的好时机，
or you might stand outside their office and wait, and then you can see when it's good to interrupt. When we're remote, we don't have that visual information, and so we can just be sending electronic communications to our colleagues at all time. there's another study that I did with my postdoc, and she found that a lot of people feel that they want to go above and beyond what they ordinarily do to be able to signal to their colleagues, to their supervisors that they're working hard, and so they jump to answer their email, their Slack messages so that they can demonstrate, hey, I'm very. working. You know, you don't see me, but I want you to know that I'm here and I'm working hard.
或者你可能会站在他们的办公室外等待，然后你可以看到什么时候打断是好的。当我们远程时，我们没有那种视觉信息，所以我们可以一直向我们的同事发送电子通讯。我与我的博士后做了另一项研究，她发现很多人觉得他们想超越他们通常所做的，以便能够向他们的同事、他们的主管发出信号，表明他们工作努力，所以他们跳起来回答他们的电子邮件、他们的Slack消息，以便他们可以证明，嘿，我非常。工作。你知道，你看不到我，但我希望你知道我在这里，我工作很努力。
And that's why I'm going to jump on these messages. Now, we've been talking a lot about what individuals can do regarding better attention spans. But are there changes that organizations should be making or even changes at a societal level that could help all of us with, you know, sort of boosting our ability to stay focused on important things? There are. And I'm a big advocate for changes on a collective level. And the reason is that if any individual decides to just, you know, pull out and completely cut themselves off from technology, they might penalize themselves. If you're a knowledge worker of any kind, you're cutting yourself off from important work communications. You can be cutting yourself off from communications,
这就是为什么我要跳到这些消息上。现在，我们一直在谈论个人在更好的注意力持续时间方面可以做什么。但是组织应该做出改变，甚至在社会层面上的改变，可以帮助我们所有人，你知道，某种程度上提高我们专注于重要事情的能力吗？有的。我是集体层面变革的坚定倡导者。原因在于，如果任何个人决定只是，你知道，退出并完全切断与技术的联系，他们可能会惩罚自己。如果你是任何类型的知识工作者，你正在切断自己与重要工作通讯的联系。你可能会切断自己与通讯的联系，
from family, friends, loved ones, from important news in the world. So it's not always beneficial for any individual to cut themselves off. But an organization can do things. They can, for example, control times during the day when electronic communications are sent. they can create a window of time when no communications would be sent.
与家人、朋友、亲人，与世界上重要新闻的联系。所以对任何个人来说，切断联系并不总是有益的。但组织可以做一些事情。例如，他们可以控制一天中发送电子通讯的时间。他们可以创造一个不发送任何通讯的时间窗口。
And this would be a quiet time with, you know, people can work. In our research, we find that people check email on average 77 times a day. And if you have this quiet time, at least you can curtail that checking, right? We might be able to reduce the amount of checking because you know there's no point to check. There won't be email coming. On a societal level, there's starting to be what's called right to disconnect laws. And there's one in France. It's called the El Camry law.
这将是一个安静的时间，你知道，人们可以工作。在我们的研究中，我们发现人们平均每天查看电子邮件77次。如果你有这个安静的时间，至少你可以限制那种查看，对吧？我们也许能够减少查看的数量，因为你知道查看没有意义。不会有电子邮件进来。在社会层面上，开始出现所谓的“断开连接权”法律。法国有一项。它被称为El Camry法。
There's also Ireland and Ontario have policies. So other countries are starting to pick up on this. And it's the idea that no worker can be penalized if they do not answer electronic. communications after work hours, before and after work hours. New York City tried to introduce a right to disconnect law in its city council meeting. That got shot down very quickly. And my favorite, I read the transcripts of the meeting and my favorite response, my favorite argument against it was from the Bureau of Tourism, which said, you know, we're the greatest. tourist city in the world were the city that never sleeps. So, you know, if we have right to
爱尔兰和安大略省也有政策。所以其他国家开始关注这一点。这个想法是，如果员工在工作时间之外，在工作时间之前和之后不回答电子通讯，他们不能受到惩罚。纽约市试图在其市议会会议上引入一项断开连接权法律。那很快就被否决了。我最喜欢的是，我读了会议的记录，我最喜欢的反对它的论点来自旅游局，它说，你知道，我们是世界上最伟大的旅游城市，我们是永不眠的城市。所以，你知道，如果我们有断开连接权
disconnect laws, it enables people to detach from work. And that has so much psychological benefit for individuals. You truly do need a break from work. We can't be on work 24-7, and that's that's what's happening. The borders between our personal life and work life have just blurred so that, you know, in personal time, when people are at home after work, they're dealing with work problems and work communications. People do need time to really relax, to break away from work. It's such a great psychological benefit. And if they can do that, it enables them to better retouch, reattached work the next day because they're fresh, they're replenished. So I'm a big advocate of right-to-discconnect policy.
法律，它使人们能够从工作中脱离。这对个人有很大的心理益处。你确实需要从工作中休息一下。我们不能24-7工作，这就是正在发生的事情。我们个人生活和工作生活之间的界限已经模糊了，以至于，你知道，在个人时间，当人们下班后在家时，他们正在处理工作问题和工作通讯。人们确实需要时间真正放松，从工作中解脱出来。这是一种巨大的心理益处。如果他们能做到这一点，它使他们能够更好地在第二天重新投入工作，因为他们很新鲜，他们得到了补充。所以我非常支持断开连接权政策。
Well, let me ask you a totally different question, which is, what's next for you? What are you working on now? What are the important research questions that you want to see answered? Yeah, so I would like to continue looking at our attention. I'm interested in a lot of things. I'm interested in how we can get more value from the Internet. We have this incredible resource available to us. And so rather than be upset by it because it distracts us,
嗯，让我问你一个完全不同的问题，那就是，你接下来要做什么？你现在在做什么？你希望看到回答的重要研究问题是什么？是的，所以我想继续观察我们的注意力。我对很多事情感兴趣。我对我们如何能从互联网上获得更多价值感兴趣。我们有这个不可思议的资源供我们使用。所以与其因为它分散我们的注意力而感到不安，
how can we turn that around and instead find value from it? And how can we utilize our time best and optimize our time best when we use the resources that the Internet offers without, without getting exhausted from it. And I also have been looking at teamwork, remote teamwork, and how that can be optimized, you know, because more and more companies are starting to have hybrid work and remote work.
我们如何扭转局面，转而从中找到价值？当我们使用互联网提供的资源时，我们如何最好地利用我们的时间并优化我们的时间，而不会从中精疲力竭。而且我也一直在研究团队合作，远程团队合作，以及如何优化它，你知道，因为越来越多的公司开始有混合工作和远程工作。
And what are the repercussions from that? What are the benefits from that? So I'd like to understand that better. Well, that all sounds really interesting. I look forward to seeing your subsequent research. I appreciate your joining me today, Dr. Mark. Thank you very much. Thank you so much for having me.
那有什么后果？那有什么好处？所以我希望能更好地理解这一点。嗯，听起来都很有趣。我期待看到你随后的研究。感谢您今天加入我，马克博士。非常感谢。非常感谢您的邀请。
You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingof psychology. Or on Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please subscribe and leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Wynerman. Our sound editor is Chris Kondyenne. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
您可以在我们的网站 speakingofpsychology 上找到《心理学谈话》往期节目，也可以在 Apple、Stitcher 或您获取播客的任何平台收听。如果您喜欢我们的节目，请订阅并留下评论。如果您对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，可以发送电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。本期《心理学谈话》由 Lee Wynerman 制作，音频编辑是 Chris Kondyenne。感谢您的收听。我是美国心理学会的 Kim Mills。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。